il est fort rare que les boudins soit
l'objet de tant d'intérêt et d'attention
chat potté et revêtus de leurs habits
solennelle de commandeur de la chair et
du goût les vins jura ici présent
essentiellement des messieurs ont
relooké tripoter renifler égoutter pas
moins de 37 boudin blanc nature et 12
boudin blanc truffé vous pouvez regarder
tous les boudins qui sont sur la table
ils sont tous différents
y en a pas un qui égale l'hôte ils sont
tous différents
qu'est ce qui fait la différence eh ben
c'est toujours le meilleur du goût que
nous on a en bouche depuis des années
qu'on goûte le boudin blanc et la
fermeté du boudin et puis sa consistance
chaque candidat boucher charcutier
traiteur doit fournir 8 boudin blanc
deux sont cuits par ces dames les autres
juste posé sur un plat l'ensemble
atterrissant sur la table des
dégustateurs répartis en cinq jurys sur
le nombre de routes ce qui cuit et ça
c'est pour les présentations donc voir
parce que ça changerait cuisson le
boudin blanc c'est un mélange de viande
de porc gorge filet jambon de l'est et
duff chaque candidat son secret ce
dernier réside essentiellement dans le
choix des morceaux de viande
jean françois est une véritable bête de
concours il a déjà été couronnée dix
fois par la confrérie du viking du
bocage normand au niveau de la clientèle
on nous demande toujours de
là encore ils iront sur un salon
cherbourg est les gens nous demandent
y at il des nouveaux résultats alors
donc on est obligé de continuer même si
on cherche à ne pas ralentir avant
l'aube j'ai continué d'en faire quelques
heures les résultats de ce concours
inter régionales seront mis en ligne sur
le site de la confrérie
la remise des prix du meilleur boudin
blanc 2016 aura lieu lundi prochain